hey there this is Cameron and you were
watching motion science and today I'm
going to show you how I went from a
particle preset from Stardust luminal
and you can see the preset here it's
under models miscellaneous it looks like
this very basic I'm gonna show you how I
went from that to this to this
and it's all based on a preset so here I
am back in After Effects I'm going to
create the preset or apply the preset
moving the layer back one frame so that
it's not a black frame at the very
beginning and then I'll have to do is
add a new camera and the camera that I'm
using here is 135 millimeter camera so
it's a very long lens
now I'm just gonna add keyframes at the
beginning of my timeline so that I have
an interesting angle so I'm going to
rotate the camera and I'm going to
position the camera and I'm gonna go
ahead and input specific numbers that I
know work for the camera that make an
interesting angle
now we're gonna go back into the
particle system and under model we're
going to turn the extrusion from 1400
down to 100 and there you can see now
the shapes the octagon shapes that I
used in the system under turbulence
we're going to change it to sphere so
it's only affecting a specific area of
the particle field I'm going to play
around a little bit with the turbulence
randomness as well as the amount of
turbulence
I'm also going to increase the size of
the sphere of turbulence so now there's
a lot of turbulence going on affecting
the plane of the particle system now
we're going to bring in some music this
is some music that I found off of
epidemic sound and it's just the
baseline of the music
and it'd help if I brought the sound in
where we can actually hear the sound so
I need to bring that back in time until
we see the waveform so really cool bass
sound next I'm going to convert the
audio of the bass into key frames under
animation assistant and delete the left
and right channels so I'm only left with
both channels and here's what the magic
happens so the particles react to the
audio under the turbulence field here
we're going to add an expression and
it's interpolation these time min Max
and then value so under time I always do
is highlight the T for time and then
pick with that time to the slider for
the amplitude of the audio now we need
to go into that amplitude those key
frames look at the graph editor or the
value graph and see where those numbers
are falling and the highest numbers are
up in the high 50s and the low numbers
are down around the zero so that tells
us that if we add in a minimum value of
0 to a maximum value of 50 to 60 we can
say okay we want those values to affect
the turbulence by X amount which is what
we're going to do here so now all you do
is highlight the expression areas so
we're under the minimum first and we're
going to highlight the minimum we're
going to change that to a low number and
then the maximum to a higher number at
50 to 60 and then we're gonna change the
values and I found that these actual
numbers work quite well for the bells
[Music]
[Music]
so you can see there that the turbulence
is being affected by the keyframes from
the audio so that's the big magic now
we're gonna go and we're gonna duplicate
the turbulence field and bring the
second turbulence further back in space
okay so I like how that's looking so the
next step is to add some lights and
we're need spot lights and we're going
to tent these lights like a light
pinkish color so already our particle
systems are starting looking more
interesting so now we'll just play
around with the positioning of the
lights to get to where we just you know
they look just right to us and then by
duplicating that spot light and bringing
a second light back in z space we can
light the back lights if you see here to
give it a little more depth next we're
going to start adding some effects and
the first effect we're going to add is
the camera lens blur this is just using
the camera lens blur it comes with After
Effects and key framing it to the audio
so what I did is I went through I went
through and I found sections of the
music that I liked that I felt like the
camera needed to blur in and out of
focus with those sections of music so I
went through and I keyframed
all of that but you'll see here
[Music]
and this is all just a matter of taste
but it's just going through and
fine-tuning you know when the camera
comes in and out of focus with the music
and what works and what doesn't
so next what I decided to do was set
keyframes for the camera so that it
moved in closer to the scene as the time
progressed to make the scene a little
more interesting in a little more
interesting movement
you can see here it looks a little more
interesting now so next I decided to
create another adjustment layer and add
some additional effects to that which is
my color effects for this I used color
balance and I adjusted the blues as well
as the greens and again the blues next I
applied a another adjustment layer which
I called effects and I started with my
favourite plugin which is glow
[Music]
it has just a really nice overall soft
look to it then I applied a tent effect
and I decrease the amount of tent to
give it a little more D saturated look I
also added two curves very basic s-curve
give it a little more contrast and a lot
of times all turn effects off and on to
see what's working and what's not and if
things need to be adjusted or not
then I added a red giant looks effect
and I really liked a preset that I found
in the looks package so I applied that
you can see it immediately gave it just
a more contrasting feel and I added
overall grain
[Music]
and I liked the way this looked but
there was one thing missing which was
just increasing these want few little
settings here for the highlight areas of
the depth of field effect and it
completely changed the look of it and
that's how I got this look so that's it
I hope you guys enjoyed this short
tutorial and I hope you learned
something new from it so until next time
I'm Cameron and this is motion science